hey this is presh talwalkar in this
video i'm going to teach you a math
magic trick
first pick a three digit number with
three different digits
next i want you to reverse the digits of
the number
now subtract the smaller number
from the larger number
finally i want you to add up the digits
of the result
focus on this number
and let me try and guess what number
you're looking at
okay i'm going to say that your number
is 18
was i correct
you should have gotten to 18 if you
followed the instructions correctly
if not you may want to recheck your math
so this prediction will always work but
the question is why
can you figure it out
give it some thought and when you're
ready keep watching the video where i
give a mathematical explanation for why
this trick
works let's go through each of the steps
we first pick a three-digit number with
three different digits i'll denote this
as abc
next you need to reverse the digits of
the number so that becomes cba
we now need to subtract the smaller
number from the larger number
i'll suppose that a is larger than c
so we have abc minus cba
if it were the other way you would
subtract
cba minus abc
this won't affect the rest of the video
so we can go ahead and assume that a is
larger than c and we have abc minus cpa
so how are we going to do this
subtraction
we need to consider the placeholders of
each of these decimal numbers
we have the hundreds place the tens
place and the ones place
let's write each number in expanded form
the number abc
represents 100 a plus 10b plus 1c
and 1c is equal to c
similarly the number cba will be 100c
plus 10b plus 1a
and once again 1a is equal to a
we can now subtract out like terms to
get a result
we have 10 b minus 10b which will be
equal to zero
we then have a hundred a
minus a and that will be equal to 99 a
we finally have c minus 100 c and that
will be negative 99 c
we can factor out the 99 to get 99 times
the quantity a minus c
so how do we proceed from here we need
to know what values of a minus c are
possible
since a is larger than c
we could have any whole number value
between 1 and 9.
so if we substitute in these we're
looking at the multiples of 99
and it could be any of the possible
values
so at this stage i've asked you to add
up the digits of the result
and if you do that you'll see that every
single result will always be 18
and that's the reason that this trick
works
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions that you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description